what they saw is that across all three
workouts at different training
intensities different uh different
amounts of reps per sets
uh all three of those workouts resulted
in on average about six kilocalories
being burned per minute and with a
relatively tight range as well from
about four to about eight kilocalories
per minute so i think that
gives us a decent heuristic uh that
people in the gym are burning probably
somewhere in the neighborhood of about
six calories per minute and then when i
thought about when i thought about it a
little bit more i i like the idea
uh so
i i like the idea of that being an
estimate and being kind of a
self-correcting estimate uh in most
contexts so first just kind of to pass
the the sanity check like does six
kilocalories per minute seem to make
sense so you can compare that to
something that is much better understood
so energy expenditure um during
uh during endurance training or just
walking and basically six cal
kilocalories per minute would equate to
walking at about 3.6 miles per hour or
like a 16 17 minute mile
which which feels about right um it's a
brisk walk yeah yeah so like a brisk
walking pace
uh burning about as much energy as a
resistance training session that that
feels about right to me so you know
during a training session like obviously
like maybe you do a hard set of squats
that's obviously very energy intensive
but then you're gonna rest
and by the end of your rest interval
before your next set uh you've probably
like calmed down to the point that like
now whatever you're experiencing is is
an intensity of uh metabolic and
respiratory output that's way lower than
it would be for walking and so it you
know it undulates but over the course of
a session can i see resistance training
being about as energy intensive as a
brisk walk yeah i think so so that that
passes the sanity check
um
and then in terms of it being
self-correcting
like if you're doing
if you're doing like really
heavy high-volume training so we've
talked about this on the podcast before
um
the amount of energy you burn resistance
training
scales
quite well with the total amount of just
physical work being performed so if you
squat
200 pounds for a set of 10 you're
burning about as a third as much energy
as someone who's squatting 600 pounds
for a set of 10 like you're
if anyone who's strong enough to do 600
for 10 you're [ __ ] dead at the end of
it uh whereas you know if 200 for 10 is
is your 10 rep max you're probably
breathing hard at the end but you're
you're not very close to meeting your
maker um and that's just because there's
a huge
difference in energy expenditure but
then on the flip side you're going to
rest way longer after that set of 10 at
600 pounds versus maybe getting back
under the bar a minute two minutes later
after the 200 for a set of 10. so
basically the more energy intensive the
sets you're doing are just kind of
naturally the longer you're going to
rest uh on the back side of it um
so i think that it's uh i think that
it's something that does self-regulate
pretty well where
you we can probably assume that most
people
over the course of an entire session are
probably burning energy at a somewhat
comparable rate probably dependent to
some degree on just their overall level
of aerobic fitness with people who are
more fit just resting shorter amounts of
time on average than people who are less
heroically fit but there there is kind
of that inbuilt regulatory mechanism in
place
um
and so yeah i i do think that that seems
like a pretty decent uh heuristic to
roll with
um
it is worth noting that it that it does
probably break down for certain types of
workouts so you know if you're doing a
workout that's just
like
10 singles and you're resting 10 minutes
between each single to make sure you're
fully recovered
you're probably not burning six calories
per minute
or if you're doing like a high intensity
interval training circuit specifically
for the purpose of of trying to make
your resistance training as
metabolically challenging as possible
it's probably going to be above kind of
that top end of this estimated range of
about four to eight kilocalories per
minute so you know
there there are types of workouts for
which this heuristic probably doesn't
apply but for
most just kind of like normal uh
resistance training workouts it's
probably gonna get you in the right
general ballpark